بس لكن هل يمكن القيام بدور تشريعي وسياسي
دون احزاب الا يخشى
المرور او الانتقال من برلمان فوضى الكتل
الى برلمان الصوت الواحد هذا سؤال يعني
يسال كثيرا في الشارع التونسي
او الاحزاب لم تمنع من المشاركه في
الانتخابات او مشاركه في الحياه السياسيه
السياسيه بدليل انها الى يومنا الحاضر
لازلت تعقد اجتماعات ولا زالت يعني تعقد
ندواتها بكل حريه وهي حاضره في وسائل
الاعلام المختلفه وتشارك يعني في الحوارات
وبالتالي فهي هي التي اختارت يعني
الانعزال واختارت التقوقع وعدم مشاركه في
الانتخابات ولكن في المستقبل قلت انها
ربما ستستخلص يعني
العبره من موقفها السلبي وستشارك في
الحياه السياسيه في المستقبل وعلي اتحال
كل حزب ما هي دور الاحزاب دور الاحزاب هي
اولا تاثير مخالطيها ثم تعبيتهم في
المواعيد الانتخابيه لانها على الاحزاب ان
تقوم بتاطير مخالطيها
وتهيئهم الانتخابات ثم لا تدعوهم للمشاركه
في الانتخابات في المواعيد المستقبليه
وعليه حال لا يوجد قانون
البرلمان الحالي فيه كتل عنا سته كتل يعني
تكونت
وستنشط يعني داخل البرلمان ولكن يعني هناك
يعني بعض
الاحكام التي
اقرها الدستور وهو عدم
يعني
القضاء على السياحه الحزبيه لا يجوز
الانتقال من كتله الى كتله هو في الحقيقه
والواقع يعني المظاهر التي شاهدناها في
السابق في شراء ذمم يعني السماح بانتقال
نواب من حزب الى حزب وانتقال النواب من
كتله الى كتله هذايا اصبح يعني محاذر ومن
اختار الى كتله عليه ان يبقى بتلك الكتله
واذا انسلخ عليها يبقى يعني نائب يعني
مستقل وغير منتمي ويواصل يعني
تحمل مسؤوليته البرلمانيه بتلك الصفه
موضوع الخلافات بين الكتل ما هي الاولويه
في حلها هل الجدل الحقوقي والايديولوجي ام
تغيير التشريعات كلها والتركيز فعلا على
الدوله الخدميه او الاداره والخدمات
للمواطنين اذا اردنا ان
نجعل المواطن التونسي يشعر بتغير في في
اداره الدوله
بالذات يعني الدستور التونسي يعني
وضح وان الدوله ثلاث وظائف في الوظيفه
التنفيذيه والوظيفه التشريعيه والوظيفه
القضائيه ومن يراقب هذه الوظائف هو الشعب
من خلال الاستفتاء والانتخابات وما الى
ذلك فمن هو مسؤول على سياسه الدوله هي
الوظيفه التنفيذيه رئيس الجمهوريه
والحكومه التي تساعده في ذلك ومن هو
مسؤوله
البرلمان من اجل المساعده والمساهمه في
التغيير
بطبيعه الحال قلنا وان الدستور سمح للنواب
وعددهم لا يقل على عشره يعني يقوموا
بمبادره لتقديم مقترح قانون وهذا المقترح
يعني يقع دراسته وفي سوره المصادقه عليه
يصبح يعني قانون سري مفعول
وكنت اسلفت القول وانه هناك العديد من
النواب الذين يفكرون في اعداد مشاريع
قوانين وفي اعداد يعني مقترحات قوانين
سيقع عرضها بصوره نظاميه على اللجان ذات
العلاقه ثم عرضه على الجلسه العامه
للمسابقه عليها